[Music]
n
hello everyone and welcome to the film
courage live stream we have the honor of
having writer teacher and podcast host
of drinks with Tony Mr Tony duchaine
live and in person to instruct us do
some live Q&A and share a couple of
writing exercises with us Tony it's
great to have you here welcome thank you
happy to be here yeah likewise and
especially for those of you not in La we
have a light drizzle here on the Mean
Streets of Los Angeles we know angelinos
do not like to go anywhere in the rain
so we appreciate you braving the storm
Tony my Harley with the monkey bars
works fine in the rain good good all
right well let's Dive Right In um I
guess we'll start with what makes a
great
scene yeah that's and scene workor is
interesting because in when we talk
about scene work all we really need is a
character or we need more than one
character but the character needs
conflict so we want to keep our
characters in as much conflict as
possible and there's a film I always
bring up to my students who and I make
them watch it over and over again
because a Little Miss Sunshine carries
the torch of seen by scene of hitting
conflict shifting power dynamics which
is also another word for shifting status
um I feel like that comes up more in TV
shows and TV scripts the shifts of
status and it's so powerful that when we
see it in a movie um it's it's pretty
cool so when I'm rewriting a scene I go
over who has status in the scene and
then is there a way to play with it so
I'll do an example of a cop
interrogating suspect so there's a cop
and he's interrogating a there it is a
cop interrogating a suspect and the cop
has high status and the suspect is in
handcuff the suspect may even be crying
and the suspect has low status so when
you're watching a scene think about
power dynamics and think about status
because that's what actors are thinking
about and that's what writers are
thinking about when they're writing and
actors are thinking about that when
they're playing
together but we can shift we can shift
that dynamic because in let's say in the
same scene the cop has information the
suspect has information that the cop
wants
so then the
cop realizes this and maybe the suspect
smiles and the cop slams his fists on
the table and he's upset as the suspect
is not giving him this information and
all of a sudden the suspect is higher
status and the cop has lower status the
cop wants something from the suspect
needs something from the suspect and the
suspect isn't giving it up so when
you're watching films keep an eye out on
this on the status and power dynamics
and watch how the protagonists can go in
and out of high status and low status in
scenes like in uh here's the example of
um Little Miss Sunshine we're introduced
to Richard Richard is Richard is talking
about his life coaching his I forget
like it's like five principles for being
the amazing man you are meant to be and
he's commanding the stage as he's you
know eyeing the crowd and going over his
presentation
and then the camera turns around and it
shows us how many people are in the
audience there's like maybe 10 and he
get a tepid Applause so the director the
director gave us a power Dynamic shift
we thought we were seeing a very high
status person almost talking to a
stadium of people and then we realize
he's low status and it's practically a
conference room and no one really cares
what he's saying so uh it's it's a lot
of fun and that's and that and that's
when Richard goes back down the low
steps refuse to lose that's what it is
right the nine
[Music]
conss and speaking of Little Miss
Sunshine of all characters in the film
who has the the biggest sort of status
shift yeah that well our the the
character with that has the most Arc is
Richard the dad because and when we look
at Little Miss Sunshine Richard is the
protagonist um because he's the one that
needs to take the journey and to learn
so when we get to act three he has The
Showdown with himself to finally get out
of this facade that he's creating as a
you know guy with a master plan and
everyone needs to succeed and he makes a
fool of himself at the end with his
daughter which just that scene
always um really gives me chills when I
watch it but um
but his his he's trying to get high
status the whole time when
he um when he gets into his low status
and kind of saves his daughter from
having embarrassment alone that's when
he has challenged himself and he has won
because he's be he's lost his status but
he's become the father he's supposed to
be for the family and the whole family
comes together when Dad kind of realizes
that wait a second I need to save my dog
that's beautiful and just real quick
which character has the least Arc in
sunshine you know Tony ket's character
the wife really has it she feels like a
placeholder and I don't know if in early
rewrites if she had an arc because a lot
of these characters have arcs um there's
Dwayne who has a that yeah that's a
great Ensemble photo uh the father has
an arc I mean he's a junkie and then he
dies um
and I don't and Little Miss and the the
young girl who plays Little Miss Sun uh
little the going to the beauty contest
she doesn't have much of an arc either
she's kind of like a placeholder um so
there's there's a lot of fun happening
um I think between Dwayne and the
brother um through a lot of the film and
that might be they may be hitting the
philosophical points of what the writer
was intending to kind of give the moral
of the story throughout I'm just
coming off of memory I haven't watched
it in about a year because that's my
first quarter students we have to watch
it over and over and over again it's so
worth it yeah I want to go back to it
it's been a while thank
you what are storytelling cheats and and
which are some that are fun to use
storytelling cheats I'm glad you asked
because I have some notes
storytelling
um if you want to a feeling sympathy for
a character some ways to get right to
feeling sympathetic um and and Blake
Snider wrote the book save the cat so
there so there's that's a way to get
sympathy immediately immediately save a
cat um but let's here here's another
example let's say a mom's just trying to
clean the house before her in-laws
arrive have her step on a Lego have her
have her step on like a tack or a nail
um when we when we when we do something
with the palm of the hand when we cut
the palm of the hand or the bottom of
the foot as we're watching it we've all
experienced that pain especially on the
foot the bottom of the foot hurts so bad
and it immediately gives us an emotional
response where we're like we've been
there we've done that so that's an
element to add to a scene if we look at
Minority Report
um uh in Minority Report everyone is
scanned by their eyeballs and so when
Tom Cruz is on the run and he's wanted
for the future murder he has to get rid
of his eyeballs it it's I mean just that
idea alone brings a massive conflict and
then and so think about what you can do
with the eyeballs can you touch the eye
can you poke the eye I through that
whole operation scene of Minority Report
with Tom Cruz it were we're like losing
our minds sure and then if we go back to
uh Little Miss Sunshine it's the a
there's a lovely thing that the writer
does which is he gives Dwayne the vow of
silence um Dwayne didn't have to have
that vow I don't know what draft of the
script where the writer went you know
what uh because the writer of the script
in early drafts could have just had
Dwayne upset and added his parents and
it would have been fine but he has a vow
silence and it escalates his tragedy so
when he finds out is caller blind and he
can't become an pilot I think he wants
to be a pilot you can't be a pilot when
you caller blind when
that plot Point happens that's the first
time he speaks and when he speaks after
he hasn't been speaking of throughout
the whole film we pay immediate
attention so it's like it's symbolic on
so many Lev
levels and the other thing about little
bit Sunshine is the BW van situation
that just make make make the BW van only
start in second
gear what what a fantastic story device
because it makes it um it makes the
family push the van and they all have to
jump in the van so there's danger
involved there's the family just being
disgusted they have to do this
and um it brings and and it's a device
that brings us to the very end of the
film it's a device because they hate
working together it's happened it's
drudgery through the film when they've
come together in the last scene as they
push the van through the parking lot
they're they're pushing the van as a
family all of a sudden we see them as
they they've all kind of been reborn
into becoming a family and so watching
them push the van is a whole new
experience for us and them and then uh
another one is Richard in Little Miss
Sunshine again Richard who uh at the
beginning of the film attempted suicide
uh they have his bandages on his wrist
through the whole film so you know props
Department I believe would be the ones
who do that and it's just a little piece
of cloth on his on his wrist but it can
but it's it's continuing to remind us
where he came from so we don't so we
don't lose track of who he is and why
he's there um those are little things so
if you just think of a prop think of a
wardrobe but they can add the character
that can symbolize something that's uh
larger for the for the
audience that's great and you also use
Ferris bu's day off oh wait we're
getting a note um yeah let's just we
have people all over the world Wonder
wonderful welcome thank you for joining
us nice West Craven hanging in the
desert in
Phoenix Craven West Craven nice I love
that guy Tomar or toor hello from Israel
hello very nice uh Eliz hello from
Nigeria hello Eliz I hope I'm saying
people's names right please forgive me
if if I've mispronounced
them have here H Ed Husker great
question hello Ed how to write a villain
protagonist yeah that's a good question
okay is there a villain in Little Miss
Sunshine well with Little Miss Sunshine
Richard is his own antagonist oh so he
needs to and that's when he has his
that's the and we get the cue to when he
has his um we get to Quee to who the
antagonist is when we look at the act
three Showdown and The Showdown is with
Richard um coming coming into uh his own
with his
family
um yes so he's his own antagonist as far
as a villain protagonist I what what do
they call that anti-heroes now which we
have great great examples of and
Breaking Bad um where they are kind of
villains to essentially the morality of
the universe that's created yet we're
pulling for them in some way
and there and that's another example of
a story cheat because we're pulling and
I got Brian Cranson plays him I can't
remember his character oh Walter White
Walter White yeah but um we we brought
in to simp empathize with him because he
has cancer and he's going to die he
wants to take care of his family
and that's the empathy that we have so
then we're on board and then he starts
to do all these terrible things so we're
still kind of on board um and that's
that's like a great example of kind of
the
anti-hero um where he is a villain in
this world of bad things happen but
we're also he's the protagonist of the
show right and I believe too there's the
scene where he and his son or the family
they go to buy jeans and and then
there's also the car wash scene and so
there's all these little glimmers where
you see like wow this guy's really I
don't know if I could hold it together
as well as this guy is he's gonna crack
at some point yeah yeah and then all of
a sudden it's just boom there we go I
don't know how many seasons it was what
a beautiful franchise though and then we
got better call Sal out of that right
right so many amazing things oh and we
have Alvin in Phoenix wow big Phoenix
following here hello Alvin very nice um
any other questions so far okay here oh
hey Dan calvisi story Maps yay woo woo
hey guys it's Dan from San Pedro okay so
yeah he's in the he's in the chat uh and
then we have someone from New Jersey
World Empire hello watch my legacy of be
okay sounds good and la la Patria Grande
as Primo Oro
from Mexico hello I'm learning Spanish
you're trying to relearn Spanish and
don't try to make me pronounce all of
that because I will ruin everything okay
great love it um hello and hman hello
what makes a good
tragedy I you know that's a good
question yeah it's a great question it's
even with the what are those two drama
figures the comedy and the tragedy right
The Masks yeah and is the
it's the tragedy and comedy are just
such in line with each other and even in
a comedy when we watch a good comedy um
the protagonist is usually in the utter
um tragedy of their condition so they're
kind of the they're taking in the the
tragedy for us while we laugh as they
get to this place so more tragedy in a
comedy the funnier and and the shift to
uh tragedy is just staying in the
tragedy I guess I guess if you think
about comedy and tragedy like it's both
tragic there's an old film that Woody
Allen did called Melinda and
Melinda um where he it was the same
characters but one story was the comedy
and one story was the tragedy and it was
the exact same dialogue oh wow yeah and
I will Pharaoh was in it and this is
just coming to my uh brain synopsises
and that's as far as I
remember what about in Ferris bu's day
off I know we were going to talk about
that is there
tragedy in that movie oh there's lovely
tragedy in movie I could talk about
Ferris buer for a week hold on okay
we're getting we're getting notes from
the producer here keeping me on track
that's
good we want to make sure to get to
everyone's questions we're this is H
we're still uh in our infancy with all
this hello RC Scott fire fire fire yeah
awesome Bea hi from Sydney
hello wow we've got a great
International audience uh currently
studying film at full sale woooo love
the amazing work great school thank you
appat tree 14 hi from Germany
storlock hello hello there I plan to
visit your country next year oh Curtis W
Jackson hello I'm from long Island nice
hello
Curtis Against All Odds films hello from
Boston Boston love
Boston and Tom's Kosco hello Tom from
ltia very Co hello very cool wow this is
a great mix here I love it hello from
New Mexico nice video speaking of
breaking bag right video gamer 65 sari
hello another great question why write
and try to get my work out there if the
chances of it being optioned or even
readed is extremely Slim in the real
world well that's a good question I got
the answer to
that because uh you're right it may
never get read there it may not be op it
might not be option it might not get out
but what I've learned through tons of
failure and a couple of kind of
successes is to embrace the process and
not only embrace the process just
realize
that you're a writer so you wake up
every day as a writer and I had someone
asked me they're like oh how do you get
your inspiration I'm like inspiration
what no I just write it's I have a
routine I have these three structural
things that I do and then I get to my
work and it's just and I do it every day
and the beauty of that is the process so
nobody can take the process of writing
away from you so you just keep crafting
stories crafting story and even when um
even when good things happen like I was
when we had our premiere of Confessions
of a Teenage Jesus jerk and I yeah got
to do Q&A and it was just it was such an
uplifting point and then the next day I
was depressed and I was like well that's
the end of that but I learn a valuable
lesson there no it's not the end of that
it's tomorrow I get to work on the other
thing I'm working on the next thing so
more important than the outcome is the
process and you have to love the process
so if you you just and you have to love
storytelling it's it's if it's your
religion you're going to show up every
day to it and um whether there's an
outcome or not and then uh like winning
like playing the lottery you got to be
in it to win it right so in order to
rate in order to have stuff to show
people you have to have a lot of writing
to show people that's finished and that
and you may be put in a good position
more often than not where people go oh
send me what you have and if you have a
lot of stuff because you've been working
hard for a long time you have things to
show them and that's where the doors
open um when there's things to show them
I hope I hope that helps your question
that the real world is being at your
desk writing every day which is such a
luxury and a cool thing to do like it's
my favorite thing to do so and you write
in coffee shops a lot too don't you Tony
yeah I do a lot of handwriting and
coffee shops I I'm the guy that never
brings a laptop and I also really hate
doing we're in La so I hate writing
screenplays in coffee shops I write
novels in coffee shops and then if I'm
if I'm working on a screenplay I'll
handr write the screenplay at a coffee
shop on a yellow pad and then bring it
home and type it in um that's my own
weird Quirk but um yeah I just I love
the long hand and then I print out I go
home type it keyboard it all in print it
all out then bring the print out the
next day and sometimes the print out
gets bigger and bigger and bigger and
before you knowe I have a binder that
I'm doing rewrites on it's uh so
whatever project that's happening early
stages is yellow pads later stag stages
is
binder and going back to what sari is
saying did anybody say the same thing to
you like hey Tony there's so little
chances of this why do it wh why why
waste your time with this well well I
mean I kind of grew up in a religion
where you weren't supposed to do
anything but you know preach so I um so
that's a little weird because I was
doing something that was so not what you
were supposed to do so I had to fight
through that uh people making fun of me
for writing and trying to write um
sometimes that's good because sometimes
I feel like people should tease people a
little bit to to see if the resolve is
there and if you can get past those
people going you can't write what do you
do what do you think you are you're
right what do you you're out of your
mind you can't be a writer and then you
get past them and and it's almost like
you walked through that first obstacle
you had the conflict you walked through
your own first obstacle and you're like
I'm
writing I love it I love it wow okay we
have
another another question oh Curtis W
Jackson I live in Bayshore okay be sure
very cool and Vlad Voodoo I'm in uh
Romania Bucharest buest I'm hoping to
visit there next fall so I'll see you
I'll see you there V what a great like
internet Hi C Gustaf hi from La nice
talk about
subtext very nice I hope you're braving
the rain Caleb Drew uh bring some
knowledge Canada Canada sorry is in the
house very cool Hello Caleb dorine
Zimmerman hello from Amish Paradise AKA
Pennsylvania Dutch Country
awesome and hi Val Deion Parker hello
this is Val from Virginia and I so
appreciate the film education being a
film courage hello Val we appreciate you
thank you for
watching and oh quenel Pompei hello a
recent graduate of La film school I love
film courage yes we've seen you many
times in the comments thank you love
seeing you here I hope I'm saying your
name right I'm sorry if I've
mispronounced anybody here
um and here we go Amelia films hello
what makes a character memorable
especially villains that's a good one I
like that question it sometimes the
villain needs to be more interesting
than the protagonists because the more
the protagonist goes through their
journey and the more interesting the
villain is the more the protagonist has
to go through the obstacle of this
interesting and powerful villain so even
though the villain is the antagonist
they are the protagonists of their story
so yeah Batman such Batman is such a
great
um example of that because because
Batman yeah okay he's kind of
interesting but the villains are always
more interesting than Batman because as
far as the TV series I don't know what
the other stuff no I'm
kidding uh but it's but but things like
Batman and Spider-Man they they hold the
center of the story and then those
villains just make those villains pop
give them the weirdest quirks in the
world um give them you don't even need
to write well I feel like you need to
write the backstory of everything and
write just and know your character
inside and out when you're putting it to
script or you're putting it to a novel
you don't need to have that all in there
you just write them from knowing what
their background is from knowing why why
they are so messed up in the head and
have this Twisted angle on life and it's
the villains are beautiful so just make
sure that um and kind of make them
lovable too I mean you I if you're
working on a character for you know say
a couple years you really gotta like you
almost have to love your character even
if they're the jerks of the film you
have to understand and have empathy
because in order to order to write and
keep the process going we have to love
our characters if we're not coming to
the mourning and writing with love
that's kind of a sad place to be I mean
come come with you know self-destructive
hate and go how am I gonna do this this
is never GNA work but at the same time
when it comes to our characters we love
them because we want to take them on the
most interesting Journey that we can put
them
through right and do you think um we
like uh characters that are more
self-destructive rather th than those
that are destructive toward others
because maybe we can relate or yeah yeah
we can relate and it's yeah I I think
you're right the the the
self-destructive ones I feel like I mean
I really hope everyone has some self
sabotaging things they do to themselves
because I'm the king of it so I
immediately relate to that whereas uh
people who have out you know I I think
so I think that's a good that's a good
uh thought because as
viewers that's easier to connect with us
when people are out when out right
pushing out and hurting other people
most of us don't do that and even when
we're at our worst we won't hurt someone
else we or you know I like Allen clothes
and be really upset but but it goes in
it doesn't go out uh if it goes out too
much there might be a sociopath type
level thing which is fun to watch so
much fun to watch not fun to be
right okay oh hello fellow citizen from
Australia
hello and oh very nice Eric $ five thank
you he has um what's your process of
incorporating supporting characters
predetermined or added as you go that's
great for me it's added as I go um I
will I write the especially in first
drafts I'm writing the characters I'm
writing the wor about as fast as my hand
can write and then um and then all of a
sudden something will show up and a
character shows up and something
interesting oh wow that's interesting
and then it's just characters start to
take place start to start to find their
way in and then some characters stay in
and some characters leave so the
character kind of has to prove
themselves and other times characters
may sound the same so you can smash
three characters into one character so
uh I add as I go but there you know
either or because predetermined is
someone who would work from an outline
and kind of come with the strug they
they can come with the whole family tree
of characters before writing a single
word and so that's where writers uh when
they just kind of understand their
process and understanding their process
is just continuing to show up to the
page every day and going oh wait I I
like the family tree of characters or I
like uh my friends me a pantser because
I I do things by the seat of my pants um
so I just like to I just like to throw
paint and then try to make it pretty
later uh by coming back to it day after
day which may not be the quickest way to
get work done but it's just the way that
I personally do it so so learning your
process is the way to go and have you
written supporting characters and then
said you know what I think this one have
to go oh yeah oh yeah no there's I kill
a lot of Darlings and um I yeah yeah I
I've had to kill a lot of Darlings over
this last
year that in the novel that I now have
finished but um oh great yeah but the uh
yeah it hurts you're like oh man but
it's you know sometimes they upstage the
the journey or the upstage of the
protagonist and it's all about serving
the story serve serve your protagonist
by creating that conflict that stays
within the um within the world that you
create very nice um it Ed Husker 473 has
a um question how to make a wrath
wrathful misanthropic character likable
oh wow um that's that's
interesting yeah you know I don't know
how likable you can get them but it
could go back to little story cheets
that we were talking about earlier you
know if we see them step on a Lego or we
see them you know if we see them um have
a human
moment um will probably be on board with
them for that human moment and that's
just little story devices to put in
there um or we can even look in their
background we can see uh we can see that
where where this where this comes
from and we may not ever want to be like
this
person um but we go oh wait okay we know
and I think we all have enough evil
inside of us that we try to keep down
that uh that we try to keep down sounds
terrible that that we we're all capable
of evil we just don't do it and so when
someone's doing it we don't like it but
if they're doing it they're also human
that that creates uh maybe more of an a
really a handshake with with the
audience and just goes oh yeah I get
people who might be able to go that to
that place I never will but wow fun
watching you do it right right oh yeah
and seeing them have a human moment or
maybe seeing that that sort of raffle
person break down and then you realize
that they're damaged and you can see the
same in yourself so yeah yeah
interesting um Andrea Ivy hello hi how
do you write your truth Write Your
Truth love it we were talking about this
uh before we went on air and um it's
something that I tell my students uh
every quarter is um it's it
is what everything's been written it's
like there there are no new stories like
people are we need original content it's
in the end um there are like maybe
shifts in how the story is told what is
original is you person you are so me who
I am today December 19th
2023 is the collection of all my
experiences the collection of all my
sorrows the collection of all my Joys
the collection of so much and so I if I
approach a story where we all say we
have um 60 bullet point outline and the
characters named and everything happens
we're all I will write it differently
than somebody else because this is where
I am at this point in my history and
other people are at different points and
has have had different things happen to
them so when you keep honest with
yourself and who you are um and
understand that you are take you are
writing from your angle on The Human
Condition or your your your camera point
of view of who we are uh everyone has a
unique thumb print on that and that's
that's the uh that's where the beauty of
this is that's where I love um watching
students uh watching their writing grow
because you know even though I can put
even though I can help them along it's
them
they're they're the ones it's extract
extract what they need to what they need
to tell in their stories
that's that's the fun stuff I love it
have you ever had a teacher tell you you
know what Tony I feel like this isn't
your truth you got to go deeper or or or
no you you've always kind of been able
to just pour it out on the page uh no I
think early on I had teachers that were
uh one of my early teachers uh like over
20 years ago uh when I first started
taking screenwriting workshops uh he
pulled me aside and he said Tony you're
a talented writer and um you're very
funny and your scenes
suck we would do we would do table reads
and he's like every table read when you
bring in the scene everyone is laughing
he's like and that's great but your
scene your your scenes just aren't
working um and so so I had to learn oh
okay now what makes a scene what makes a
scene is conflict it's power dynamics
it's and it took me years to kind of put
all that together know okay cool and I'm
sure you know and then also enjoying
that scene suck on early drafts first
second third drafts embracing that and
then knowing that you can come back and
craft because they say writing is
rewriting it's just about crafting
crafting beautiful oh we have a question
from Spruce hello from Wisconsin um how
should I approach short form
storytelling is it a different process
to feature length oh I love Wisconsin i'
I've visited lacrosse before great great
breweries
um approaching short films that it's
short films I feel like can get away
with more than featur link films I love
short films that can have a
surrealistic um
aspect to them that we may not see
exactly where everyone comes from or
where they're going uh and but we're
also investing less time in them as a
viewer so a solid 15minute film might be
a beautiful
Serene thing or you know a couple bullet
points are uh there and it's fun to play
with that I think there's less Stakes
involved with um putting together the
you know writing crew up and all that uh
when when it comes to the feature really
I mean ending in short you need a threea
structure but then the feature film
World definitely need a 3X structure
because we have all been
um kind of conditioned as audience
members we've watched films and all
films have three act structures and you
can hit the bullet points of you know
status quo and signing incident and the
First Act uh characters on on their
journey and so even though we don't
people who aren't screenwriters who
aren't interested in the behind the
scenes they know when a film is not
hitting those points because they'll be
like oh that film is kind of weird I
didn't like it that much usually it's
because they didn't hit the points
um yeah so that's I mean that's the
difference of of a feature and and a
feature is just so much harder to write
how should you approach short short film
with joy and fun and
vigor and then the feature film you're
going to war well I know with your book
uh Confessions of a Teenage Jesus jerk
you turned it into a film yes did you
ever think about doing a short or did
you do oh you didn't okay uh and that
was the insatiable delusional lunatic in
me when I was writing the book even
before I didn't know if anyone was ever
going to publish it that I already knew
it was a film too um and I never saw
anything other than a
fature um but I did I also didn't have I
I wasn't wasn't directing that uh so
there was so it was wonderful because it
was out of my control and then Eric
skz's control as the Director uh but I
had to get it right on the page for it
to for him to work forward on it okay
another question from respectable lady
respectable lady love it uh how do you
know if your idea for a script is a good
one and she says hello from Atlanta
hello Atlanta your your idea is terrible
it's it's I I say that kind of to be
funny but I say that in all
seriousness um most
people especially people who don't write
they say I have this idea for a film and
I'm like I don't want to hear it and
it's because it s it may sound okay when
you talk about it but then you put it on
the page and then I ask people who have
put this idea on the page and I'm like
and what did you think and they're like
it's terrible like yes that is the place
to be because an idea itself is is not
what anchors the story The the what
anchors the story is continuing to work
through the idea to adding characters to
it's all about character it's all about
putting the character through conflict
no matter what the idea is and I get a
kick out of bad ideas I have so many bad
ideas and then I go wait a second that's
a bad idea that I have to try and then
you just choose a bad idea and work on
it for a year or two and all sudden and
this is this is some this is something
that can happen is when you have when
you're working on something all of a
sudden all these great ideas start
appearing over here they're not great
ideas just write them down and put them
aside and stay with your project because
any idea can make a great film so that's
my that's my advice on that that's
interesting so in a sense then there are
every idea is bad but then there are no
bad ideas because if you're adding to
them not to get too yes woo woo about it
but then you're adding to them and
you're putting little puzzle pieces in
yes exactly yes it's it's I like how you
say puzzle pieces because a good idea
could just be a puzzle piece and you
look at it and go oh wait this is
nothing you put the whole puzzle
together go like
gorgeous we have another question coming
in uh Christian Coulson Christian writes
where do you stand on plot versus
character debate I know that's a Hot
Topic with writers when writing do you
prefer to focus on flushing out the plot
or diving deep into character study like
that yeah yeah for me the character is
everything uh some people start with
plot some people start with character
there but they both need to be there so
they both need to show up um we we with
without a plot the character does
nothing it just kind of stands there and
looks at you um without a character but
a great plot there's empty space so um I
feel like the character is more more
important than the plot but the plot
needs to be there so they kind of they
both have to be together I focus
personally on diving into the character
and who the character is and I feel like
maybe uh maybe even actors think about
this too because when they're working on
their character they're not thinking of
the plot they're thinking of where is
this character coming from in this scene
where is this character coming from in
another scene so yes there is a plot but
at the same time that character a strong
character can can bring us bring a plot
that doesn't have a lot of plot elements
to it I'm trying to think of a film that
is very light and plot there's a lot of
films that are light and plot but the
character just pops and they're
beautiful if there's a huge plot and the
character is not working the whole movie
dies because we're the character is the
face the character is the uh the face of
the journey that we are um um that we're
going hey I'm on this journey with you
what was the first character that stood
out for you whether in a novel or
film oh good question which just really
resonated um if here's a film well I
think I brought this up when I talked to
you guys last time Johnny suede oh yes
yes Tom Dill's first movie Brad Pitt's
first role as a feature as a first role
as a feature film actor
and um that resonated with me when I was
young a lot uh and it's yeah and I've
got to interview him about it and uh I
hanged him with question after question
he was interviewing for another film and
I'm like you know what hi can we just
talk about joining suede oh this is Brad
Pit no no this is Tom Dillo oh okay and
he's just like yeah yeah we could talk
about that like all right so oh very
cool um yeah it's uh I I haven't watched
it lately uh but it meant a lot to me
when I was younger that's one character
that really stood
out yeah it's when I think the the
important ones when I was young it was
that one I recently rewatched uh moror
and caller with um Samantha
Morton and what a beautiful I I just
love that film so much maybe because
it's about a this going to be dark but a
guy the the beginning of the film is her
boyfriend kills himself and so
immediately we brought into the conflict
but he left a book for her to send the
Publishers so she she decides to write
her name as the author instead of his
and then we see her just go through this
maniac and it's based on the book then
that might be why I also like it to
check that out bonjour bonjour oh
Matthew regnard hello from France love
the content hello hope I'm saying your
name right hello
bonjour uh Indra dupta hello from
Atlanta hello there a lot of people from
Atlanta the second Hollywood right now
right right hotlanta yeah and Alvin El
Lawrence hello Alvin would love your
thoughts what's the first thing you
would do if you were beginning to write
characters for a series oh that's a good
one that's a really good one because the
series has to carry Seasons so when
you're when you're thinking about
characters you're also thinking about
World building a lot more and and
thinking about okay I can write the
pilot and also when I'm pitching I have
to know season one Arc season two Arc
season three Arc or if you're writing a
sitcom you have to know the world of
where they have
the what do you call it the enclosed
story of each episode like a procedural
too a lot of procedurals have their
enclosed stories and it's just like and
we wrap up oh boy we got him this time
but wait till next week when we are not
sure if we'll get him
um so yeah it's if you're beginning to
write characters for a
series play with play with the beauty of
the form of the series what's what's the
series about the series has to have
Series has to have a tone unto itself
that lasts for a very long time and then
that at that point you can say a feature
film's almost a short story and a series
is a novel or series of novels and
that's when the world of is um the world
of is important in a film too but really
have fun with the world where you're
putting them even even a TV show like
friends or like Seinfeld you're putting
Seinfeld on his little you know in his
apartment a lot them friends they're all
in the cafe uh they all have their
conflicts um and for a lot of TV series
they are um they are tied in into the
sets that are created so I guess on that
note think about keeping your locations
as minimal as possible how do you keep
your locations as minimal as possible so
if you're working on film I mean if
you're working on a TV series they can
shoot as much as possible on a Sound
Stage before having to go out and do all
the exteriors is there a series that did
not uh get picked up for a second term
that you lament over yes oh great
question freaking
okay yeah Jud appow and Paul fe's uh
series and I got to interview Paul Fe
after that and um well I got to
interview him for his book and I asked
him I was like what happens in season
two what were you guys planning on
season two and he told me that um the
lead character was going to be pregnant
season two the girl I was like oh
yeah very cool maybe I know you're going
nonstop so maybe just have some water
real quick oh yeah sorry we don't we
don't need to work so hard by the way we
know the the writer strike is over and
we don't want to we're trying to go go
easy on I'm here sorry I I love I love
the the you got the headphones you're
like dude I'm here with that frog man so
we're just we're just giving Tony a
moment um there's so many great
questions that are coming in aming
trying to get it we're trying to get as
many answered as we can here yeah thank
you so much to everyone art withar r b
question when starting out as a content
creator making film is two sentence
horror shorts a good path to
follow um I don't I don't understand
that question two sentence four short
short
interesting uh okay try the next you
know forgive me I am not I don't maybe
we could get clarification sorry we
don't want to skip over I'm not I'm not
hip to that yet so I would like to know
and then I want to know and I'll have pH
with right and we have a DW hello
question in your opinion which character
traits make Colonel Jessup A Few Good
Men such a polarizing and Unforgettable
villain I just I just watched that film
this last year and sign it to my
students oh that great yeah it's um it's
it's his moral code is so stringent and
his status is always high well talk
about status play that court scene is
one of the most beautiful Court scenes
to watch in the very end where I think
it's an eight minute scene where it's
just like watching status shift from uh
Colonel jessip to the uh Tom Cruz's
character back and forth um that's just
a lot of status shifting but the what
what Colonel Jessup has as a as a trait
that is very positive and humans is he
has insatiable Drive insatiable drive to
do everything everything he can that he
feels is right to protect everybody and
even though it's utterly flawed from his
from our point of view it is not flawed
from his point of view and it's just I
feel like that it's there's just
something about it and it's just Jack
Nicholson I think reading Colonel Jessup
on the page and then watching Jack
Nicholson be Colonel Jess just so great
right and oh thir ey from our son uh
freaks hello yeah okay great uh yes I
that y I almost read it as Third Eye
Blind sorry great Band by the way yeah
so thought I yes I knew he'd say that
okay knew it I I look for
demographic who would watch Freaks and
Geeks you're perfect for a focus group
um Ben Fox hello from the UK my brother
and I are coming out to LA in January we
we uh have several stories and two
feature screenplays where would one
start in order to get a meeting or a
pitch H yeah welcome to Los Angeles and
guess what even people in Los Angeles
are asking that question it's it's it's
I moved to Los Angeles from San
Francisco and I just thought you just
showed up and people threw money at you
and you gave them you know here's my
here's my brilliant words of course
thank you I'll buy in that house um
but what I've learned even the big
writers like writers that I'm huge fans
of um they are struggling to get pitch
meetings and to and to put together uh
put put things together too everyone's
struggling even even aist writers are um
in the struggle so I don't think I don't
think just coming into Los Angeles and
expecting to get any meetings is a great
idea
unfortunately there's something about
being in Los Angeles still that feels a
little important even though I'm not
good at
pitching um I'm or maybe I I might be
good at pitching maybe I just don't do
it as much I'll talk about that with my
therapist
tomorrow but um but yeah it's if if you
if there's coming to Los Angeles for
expectation of moving the career
forward um it's that's cool but come to
Los Angeles with trying to learn the
culture of the city because the city is
so much more than screenwriting and then
all of a sudden you just kind of start
to meet people who are in the industry
you might meet them in different places
that you would never think about instead
of chatau Marmont with your $ Martini
going well I'm gonna sip this slow this
is an expensive Martini is anyone here
Lana Turner might be sitting but and in
all seriousness though not to to uh you
know disuade Ben and his brother from
coming here but if they don't have a
meeting already set up I like what you
said to to get the kind of feel of La
yeah important yeah la and you know I'm
from San Francisco and we had our nose
turned up to Los Angeles when I was
young and it's and it's um and I came to
LA and I was like don't be that San
Francisco guy and and once I once I
decided on that I like Los Angeles is a
really beautiful city it's amazing
outside of the film industry and you get
just little pockets and then all a
sudden you're in the beauty of the
creativity of what's Happening whether
it's in film or theater it's so much fun
stuff yeah absolutely absolutely and it
moves fast too so oh we have art with
Omar B back clarification here we go two
sentence horror stories are on Hulu and
Netflix they're horror stories told in a
micro short format maybe three to five
minutes okay great thank you for
clarification yeah that's new to me and
that sounds like a lot of fun I will
have to watch those okay okay great um
yeah I'll have to check that out too I
was not aware of those yeah so that's
interesting um Ed huser's back hello Ed
hello from oh Indonesia great how do I
make my characters more than just a
caricature I like that yeah um it's in
in early drafts we're just we're again
putting pain to the canvas and there
there'll there'll be caricatures and
they'll they'll be cliche and I I talked
to my students a lot where they're like
oh I'm so worried this feels cliche or
fabricated I'm like don't worry it is
cliche and fabricated but keep massaging
it and even then when you're when we
working on conflict um we are
fabricating conflict but the it's we're
storytellers so we have to take the
normal conflict of everyday life and
smash it together to make it interesting
because if we s if I mean if if let's
say I'm a character through my life and
like like driving on the Los Angeles
freeways it's um that might be a story a
very boring story um but it's uh but
then again maybe there's something in
that where there could be a film the
point of you of a guy driving Los
Angeles freeways and with that is when
we go to the craft and keep going hey
that's a really dumb idea feel free to
take that dumb idea but it's it's
something where oh wait okay this
character can do this this character can
can go there it's showing up to the page
every day that's that's the main thing
just show up show up show maybe you're
driving and you hear an NPR story and
then you actually forget where you're
going it's so interesting and you want
to write about it and now your life's
totally shifted course I don't know yeah
yeah or you call the NPR station and you
go I really like that story and then all
of a sudden you're married to the person
answering the phone yeah yeah five years
two years later you know it's just can I
get your number me at this Cafe that's
what happens in Los Angeles very true
very true uh leaport hello from Britain
I'm writing my first TV series I'm
halfway through episode three of about
six and I'm really losing motivation to
write oh that's a good question how do
you self motivate during moments of
self-doubt thank you yeah I lose
interest too in stuff that's a great
question I love this question so all
this question says to me is you're a
writer it's it's um we the getting
through the mo self motivation and
getting through the self-doubt is what
writers do to get to their end and
that's why people find it so hard to
write because you're going to hit that
wall and it's it's almost like you just
got to show up with that self-doubt one
thing I try to do I'll work on a
different project if I'm having a really
really hard time with the current like
if I'm halfway through a a project I'll
do some short little writing thing that
may never ever get published or or maybe
even write outside of what with those
characters of something else um just to
kind of bring some freshness back to it
and then just and then you got to come
back in and just feel like an impostor
and feel like there's just no way uh
you're going to do anything right but
you continue to just
plug away and ask questions well where
would it where does this go here and
I'll even write the questions I'll just
be like um I'll have my characters ask
me questions I'll I'll write their
questions down and then I try to answer
them and that has gotten me out of some
uh some stuck places as well so it's uh
just I what your question just proves
you're a writer so and prove it even
more to get to episode six with all that
that self-doubt and that hard motivation
to sit down with it every day I love
that and you know sometimes it seems
like if things are messy around us maybe
it's time to just kind of like clean
them up and then make sure everything is
like within its place and we can kind of
get a new spark again I don't know
that's yeah declutter right it's the
there's there's declutter and then
there's repainting to avoid oh okay okay
so then some of it might be avoidance
all right maybe I'm giving bad advice no
you're not that's actually no that is
something to shake it up we want that
that would I would think that's shaking
up our environment you know shake up the
environment even more and go to a park
and right for a while and see if that
you know Works may not work may be a
very bad idea and is that what helps you
being in coffee shops because it's such
a different environment every day um
yeah and I plus people irritate me so
uh in coffee shops I get a little
irritated and then that I don't know
what it is and I never really put my
finger on the why but it just
um it's I think I need to be vaguely
irritated in order to be selfmotivated
interesting which is kind of great in
society because she could you irritated
with anything sure sure especially La is
very crowded yeah yeah yeah hello from
Brazil hugs from Brazil Yuri Silva hello
this content is made from love thanks oh
that's
nice oh thank you thank you Yuri and uh
Jessie B Styles hello my name is Jesse
nice to meet you both my question is if
you don't know how to write a movie
script but you have several movie
scripts mapped out in your head from
beginning middle to end H so you have I
guess sounds like you have the
ideas uh would you what would you advise
well would you talk about maybe starting
with one
yeah yeah yeah several movie scripts
yeah yeah start with start with one and
stick with it that's that's the uh and
it's hard it's not easy to stick with it
but
um and also read read screen plays and
watch films like an insatiable
sponge um watch them over and over again
and just see what the see what the
actors are doing see what the directors
are doing and then see how you put how
can you put that on the page I years ago
I used to write um I I would watch a
film and I would write the screenplay as
if I was writing it by watching a scene
so almost like just transcribing what it
would look like on paper um just to
start to just to start to understand
exactly what the um what it felt like to
write a screenplay and somebody already
wrote it for me and then I can write and
then I can just copy it and that's you
know I years ago I used to do that with
books too I would just be like oh my God
I love this book and I would handwrite
the first chapter of the book just to
know what it felt like to have a
relationship with those words in that
way now for a new writer what's your
viice on handing over the first draft or
second draft to someone that's not a
professional writer but maybe he's close
to
you yeah I I I advise um I advise
getting into writer groups are taking
classes because then you'll then you'll
be with other writers who are trying to
do who are trying and doing their thing
and that would be like more like a peer
thing I feel like if we just show it to
friends who aren't writers or
necessarily have too much interest in
Reading in general if they're not
insatiable readers uh it it could just
could put us off especially in those
early stages we we want to be looking
for our for our camaraderie and the
people who are just as delusional as we
are because we think we have this idea
that's actually going to work and then
we work on it we we're looking for those
people to just kind of be around and
then we can go hey what do you think of
this is this a thing and they can look
at it and go it's not a thing but here's
why I think it's not a thing and there
could be more of a conversation that
great advice great
advice uh from primary buffer panel
hello from Britain I really should be a
sleep um can you have several yeah we
can have several the the the the the the
uh maybe oh here we go hello uh all
Hydraulics hello from Spanish Fort
Alabama thank you for sharing your
incredible experience and knowledge oh
very nice hello from Orlando
hello very nice um Michael Martin Dylan
hello from Toronto I just got a film
through a bunch of film festivals and
I'm wondering how exact L awards are
determined we beat and lose to the same
people in different spots now that's a
good question yeah that's good um that's
a scary
question I think you stumped Us Michael
Martin Dylan I think yeah I I don't know
I don't know how I don't know how
festivals work with Awards I don't even
know how the Oscars work with Awards
it's it's a yeah um I think there's a
marketing department when it comes to
the a like isn't there like they put
more budget to actually marketing the
movie for Oscars than actually
correction sometimes so sure and and I'm
assuming these are feature uh feature
films referring to congrats getting him
into the film festival though having an
audience yeah wish we had a more of an
answer but that's that's an interesting
quandry um V Martin hello from Deep
South Texas when did you realize slash
accept oh I like that that except that
you were a writer did you have the
conflict deciding between the artistic
life and being a quote Normie okay well
I got an answer this we actually had
this conversation before we started yeah
I have an answer to that question I used
to be an army I'm still kind still kind
of an noring um here I read a I read I
and I may have said this actually when
we interviewed before but um there's a
book by new hampson called hunger and I
read that and and I been reading for a
while but I've been working also in like
Tech and things like that and also doing
like College radio I was kind of like
floundering around and when I read that
I I realized oh man I gotta I gotta I
gotta write and that's when I um quit my
tech job and started because the tech
job was fun but it was life consuming so
instead of doing Tech I just went and
did temp work and was a file Clerk or
whatever so I can just leave it at work
and come home write um and that's when I
that's when I decided that uh that I'm
going to be a writer uh till the death
and um and it was a very poor decision
and I should have stayed in Tech
financially now for soul for for my soul
it was everything I needed to do and so
I feel very
lucky um yeah so just just see just see
if it see if um
see if you see if you need to tell your
stories not everyone needs to tell their
stories for me I need to tell my stories
it's it's
urgent when I wake up in the morning
that I have stories in progress and I am
so happy that that's my life was there
was it building up to many years of you
deciding to leave the tech industry or
was it a fast exit kind of it was I was
in it for about two two and a half years
it was pretty fast um and I just
realized it wasn't me I do love and that
here's the um I love solving problems I
love puzzles and you can do that in Tech
and you can also do that in writing
because in writing all we're doing is
when our on our first draft we're
creating problems we we're just creating
huge problems for ourselves that we need
to fix almost like if we were debugging
software we need to debug our um um our
our writing to make it better and
continue to work on the puzzle which is
the how do I make this as perfect as I
could than
you that's great I like that uh primary
buffer panels okay um here we go so then
hi from Britain I should be asleep I
write short stories
70k words okay uh but always have
trouble with philosophical conflicts my
question is we have several philos
philosophical conflex or or will excuse
me will having several conflicts make
the story messy philosophical conflix
isn't 70,000 words more like a novel or
would it be a Nolla yeah I think that's
hitting close to novel uh okay because I
mean the novel I'm shopping now is like
65,000 so oh okay um and that clocks in
around like 220 Pages or so but um
philosophical com yeah it's
I I'm not exactly sure the context of
the question but if it's like philos
philosophical philosophical conflict and
like the moral of the story I feel like
honing in on
one um specific almost a message that
you want to get across it could be other
messages throughout the uh the work but
one message that's the Arc of the of the
entire um almost a theme that's that's
when the word theme comes in what is the
theme and the theme I feel like needs to
have some spec some be specific on um on
certain levels and then that's when we
are totally engrossed and and we may not
even want you know a regular viewer is
not going to walk away and go I really
like the theme of that because they'll
just go I really like that film I don't
understand why I got it but it's
because um the theme was
uh was uh hit one one theme I wish I had
examples uh but in oh yeah but in in
novels I personally I try to keep it to
one and then have little ones in between
but those little ones all go to the
large the larger Central um
philosophical moral quandry
sort I like that that's great uh here we
go store hello do you think that it's
important to show an aftermath at the
end of the movie to show that the
protagonist has really learned his or
her lesson that's good that's a great
question we can go back to a little bit
of sunshine on this because if you get
the DVD there's actually a longer
ending than what was that what came out
at the movie theater they shot an ending
that Mo that so after they all worked
together to get the van working again
and then they jumped in the van and they
got on the freeway and then they're on
the freeway and then it's like fade out
what a beautiful ending but they had
another scene where they go to a car
where they they go to like one of those
rest stops and they're all eating and
they're like man wasn't that that was
just crazy yeah that was crazy I'm glad
we did that thing oh my God we totally
did the thing and we're together now
this is fun and um it's a scene that
made it from the beginning script to
production to post production and then
was cut so um sometimes not
showing the aftermath which would be
Richard's aftermath and then the family
together is more powerful because it
already showed it when they when they
all just worked on together on getting
that van back on the road
um and yeah I I'm trying to think of a t
of other ones where people learn their
lessons and we get to Rebel Revel in the
joy of them learning their lessons I
can't I don't have any thoughts or
examples in my head at the
moment right oh we have another one I
let you um pause for a moment and
um I know this is rapid fire for you
here Tony I'm sorry we're we're excited
and and trying let's give it up for Tony
yeah energy Bo energy Bo hit me keep
hitting me on go I know it's like it's
like a boxing ring um
s hello thanks for doing this my
question is if you have a story where
the hero's journey is very emotional but
you personally have never felt that way
in your life and how do you connect with
the hero great question love it yeah
um what why I my follow-up question
would be why would you want to write
that story and work on it for a long
time because
um I mean there are so many stories that
we can write why not write the story
that emotionally touches us I I think
that's a writing question right yeah I
guess basically saying it may forgive me
if I'm assuming here sayum um that we're
trying to write something that uh maybe
is interesting to us but we've never
actually felt that way um I guess you
know you can tap into so many different
things I mean you too you see people out
and about in La do you does that feed
your sort of creativity even though if
it's just for one little Glimpse and
they're ordering a latte and you've
already sort of determined what their
life is
like oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I know we
talked about that before I think yeah
that's fun um yeah it's yeah I mean it's
and even tapping into characters that
we're not emotionally connected with
it's to tap into them I don't feel like
I would want to work on a protagonist
that I'm not totally emotionally
connected with um on some
level uh and then but the other
supporting characters we don't
necessarily have to have the same
emotional um uh the emotional Cadence or
whatever who you know of who they are
but understand them from an
angle and we may it could be someone we
don't like but at the same time we have
to find the empathy because we're
working so hard on something why would
we want to work with something that
drives us crazy even though working just
drives us crazy so we're already driven
crazy why not why not di in I guess and
Hunter S Thompson he didn't know all of
the worlds that he he eventually wrote
about he went to sort of inhabit them
sure advis that for everybody but yeah
he he took his own sort of Gonzo
approach yeah yeah right um all
Hydraulics is writing again how long
have you held on to a bad or stale idea
in hopes that will develop sometimes six
months uh no sometimes even
longer then and I've tossed them and I
went wow and what I and I don't think of
those as uh failures I think of those as
I never want that to see the light of
day and but I learned I kept going um so
that was
uh yeah it's it's continuing the process
where I maybe I had to write that in
order to get to the next thing that I
had to write maybe I had to go through
that exercise which is a very positive
spin on it and I don't know where that
came from oh well I like it you're
channeling your um inner life coach yes
exactly Tony giving advice to Tony I
like it the nine
steps uh let's see from Ark Mish a
question on theme if there is a movie
about stories of three generations of
the same family does the underlying
philosophical conflict in all three
stories need to be the same for all wow
that's great that is such a great
question I wish I had an answer for that
um because I guess I don't I don't
really connect personally with the
stories that have like tons of dimension
of family Generations where if it says
it on a book flap or it says it on a
film my immediate response is is uh I
probably won't watch it uh so I and that
doesn't mean that it's bad it just means
that it's something that I don't consume
so that I don't have an answer for that
sure I mean I'm thinking of two like uh
trauma that that is is sort of carried
on from one generation to the next so
maybe these people are living out the
residual trauma you know I I don't know
that's one thought
yeah maybe at this stage um we can
transition to where our first writing
exercise yes who wants a writing
exercise I do okay we're gonna do a
writing exercise let me see which one I
had queued up because we
got and thank you to everyone for your
questions and it's it's great to see
everyone in the
chat yeah so for a writing exercise this
is um here's the thing about writing
exercises especially in this scenario
these are free writing exercis exercises
so you get the rules of the exercise and
then just write don't stop writing and
even if you forget the rule just keep
writing um just see what happens the the
rules aren't as as important as the
continuing of the writing on the paper
or on the
keyboard um so with our first writing
exercise um this is the this is the
happy woman is that is that yes
so there we go so um we'll guide you
through this will be a two-parter so uh
name her what's her name and usually our
gut instinct gives us a name right away
and usually that's the correct name so
um and what is she happy about don't
tell us that's for my live that's for my
live classes when I'm at the library
like don't say it but I want you to find
out I want you to think about you see
her happy what is she happy about and
then write why she's happy and just see
where the writing takes you what is does
she have a goal that she wants to
achieve and she's just so excited about
it and for like seven minutes just just
dive into this woman that you've already
named you kind of know what she's happy
about just
write why she's happy and write this
goal that she had that she's just so
excited about the seven minutes a good
idea
on let maybe three three to five minutes
three to five minutes there we go um so
so yeah for three minutes think it's
three minutes and don't worry about time
just just continue to write until we
come back and then we'll have the second
part
the
okay we are
back so we have the four questions
what's her name what is she happy about
and don't tell us number three write why
is she happy and see where that takes
you and number four what is the goal she
wants to achieve that she's so
excited and if yeah if uh and then if
you feel like there's more then um deide
after this uh after you watch this
stream and keep playing with it and then
um so yeah um and now for every
protagonist there's an antagonist so
even if you wrote in an antagonist of
sorts uh this is uh this one is
monumentally more evil um even more
Twisted it is so
Sinister uh than any other being on
Earth come up with the name of your ant
antagonist and let's show the photo of
the antagonist they're going to
write terrible
terrible
character this is it now remember the um
the antagonist is meant to get in the
way of our protagonist our protagonist
is Happy essentially she has a goal
she's so excited about it so name this
antagonist and write about this Sinister
antagonist and what it does to thwart
your protagonist
goals
here okay so we are back and we'll
finish up this exercise and then maybe
we'll take a few more uh questions and
then we have another exercise after that
so we'll do a couple more uh
questions thank you to everybody in the
chat for your questions and uh you know
shout outs um okay here we go from video
gamer 65 most of my collaborate
collaborators are very new to writing as
their mentor and friend what is a good
way to introduce them to writing what
are some good introductory concepts for
them that yeah um even the free writing
exercise that we just did just kind of
really gets our head in the game um I
feel like especially when those when you
have rules set and you have a time limit
um our right brain kind of our right
brain kind of takes over our left brain
and so it's just oh wow I got to get
this done so our intellectual side is
not going hey you don't need to do it
that way you just keep writing so I
guess just keep playing being playful um
in your writing as writers though we
need to be reading constantly too uh and
that's um that's so important because we
need with the conversation can't just be
us writing the conversation is we need
to receive as well so we so we read
constantly we write constantly and so if
they're not insatiable readers uh I
would you know encourage them to just
try to read every day too write every
day read every day it's a it's a
relationship we want to continue to
develop what do you think about uh
fiction uh through You Know audio
instead of actually what if you don't
have time to sit down and read but you
can have it playing while you're doing
the dishes something yeah I you know I
must confess I've never listened to an
audio book before okay I know and it's
2023 and that's my problem but um okay
thank you for your confession by the way
I feel so bad but uh but I feel like the
thing is it's about the page so if some
somebody's going to Maybe audio record
their stories for podcast or something
then that would be where you listen to
the story and if if you you know if you
need to read if you're at the gym and
you're like I just want to listen to an
audio great um I listen to a certain
podcast and it's uh mostly from
comedians but I'm not I'm not out to go
do any standup comedy but when it comes
to like reading on the page I think it's
just that relationship with the page we
read on the page we write on the page so
continue to keep the eyeballs you know
moving in this direction as you read and
then they're moving in this direction as
you write it's just kind of a brain
function okay great another question uh
has come in Alexandra O'Neal hi
Alexandra how do you write meaningful
dialogue yeah that's a good question a
lot of that's the point of view of the
characters and also make your
characters in Conflict here here here's
an example of um
of dialogue where say our characters
agree with the outcome so like our
characters might agree with something
which is fine but being agreeable
doesn't make an interesting scene what
makes an interesting scene is how they
how committed they are to their personal
point of view of how that outcome is
going to play out so we see this in a
lot of like buddy cop movies we see this
in certain films where they all agree
that this needs to happen but they their
hyperfocus on how they're going to make
it happen and then you can just develop
that dialogue as a tip or tap between
these people um and also in rewrites
just pair down the dialogue they say
early drafts make that dialogue section
like this and then in if you can get
that Dialogue on to one line and convey
everything you had in that paragraph
that's when it's really tight and also
remember that when we're writing for the
screen writing for actors who are going
to convey so much just with their facial
expressions with how they've embodied
the characters so always remember to try
to stay out of the way of the actor when
we can that's
great okay and okay so primary buffer
panel very fun exercise thanks I think I
need to sketch the story out now yeah
inspiring yeah you never know what
happens and it's yeah it's fun and uh Ed
Husker 473 should I write the story then
revise it when it's when it was done or
if if you're talking about the current
story if you want uh the one the writing
exercise I'm assuming is uh the question
and if you want great and if if it seems
interesting to you and you're like oh
wait I can go somewhere with this dig in
work on it for a week if you're still
digging in work on it for a month it may
lead you to a different story or it may
be a similar story where a cute little
puppy is the antagonist that would be
awesome it's uh so yeah find what's find
what touches you that you're going to
get up to and work on every day and it
and it may just be this story for a week
or two or this story may be a feature
film and you can let us know and tell us
where to watch it when it comes out
great uh let's see Grim Lord G would you
read old
scripts yes yes that's always me reading
is always always reading scripts
too yeah and it's fun too when to read
some of the older old classic films
right my students say classic films they
mean fah spieler day off when I say
classic films I mean Billy Wilder but
you uh let's see forgive me if I'm
saying your name incorrectly uh chillen
Washington how many new writers say
something about the business of writing
entertainment business industry I don't
hear enough about
that the business of writing that's a
great that's a great question yeah some
people are really good at that I don't
feel like I'm so good at it that's why I
always try to work work my get my work
through you know do put my work through
the channel of agents and um when you
know if they'll have me or other people
who can do the business uh even though
we do it even though it's a necessary
evil to do the business it's
um yeah you know in a in a perfect world
we uh we just want to be creative and
have people come knocking on our door
and go what do you have today for us
thank you kind sir uh but it's yeah I'm
not good on the business side of it I'm
trying to be better um
so yeah maybe that's maybe that's
something where it's if you're so right
brained and the left brain brain is not
you know that that like you said that's
why you hire agents and managers because
you can do the right brain and the left
brain some people the left brain is no
problem the right that's you know yeah
um Andre weight hello from Colorado uh
can you please go over the First Act and
the central
question oh wow yeah so I mean the First
Act the story beats are a status quo of
our protagonist so we see where the who
the protagonist is we we talk about um
Rich from uh Little Miss Sunshine so we
saw his status quo
as um he was just driven every you know
are you gonna win your winner he even
tells it to his poor daughter when
they're like um gonna go to gonna drive
to go to the beauty contest do you feel
like you're gonna win we have a winner
and it's just it's it's so sad it's and
it's his tragedy so we have his status
quo then we have the inciting incident
but the inciting incident happens pretty
early in Little Miss Sunshine where they
get the phone call that's hi she's in
the little bit of sunshine so there's
our inciting incident now now what are
we going to do and then all of a sudden
there's all these complications with
Lake Snider and some other um uh people
who talk a lot about Beats they would
call this the debate area so they're
just like well my brother just tried to
kill himself he can't be alone well it's
so there so they scramble around that
and then they go okay you know what
let's go we're going to do it so in
Little Miss Sunshine it's kind of like
those three beats status quo inciting
incident and then it's just the hero
goes ah no what how is this going to
work I no no no okay let's go and then
there's the that's just the point of no
return in your that too um as far as the
central question I think it shows up in
act one like if we look at little
sunshine the central question is here's
a dysfunctional family how are they
going to get out of this crazy
dysfunction we and and for people you
know even I had to watch it a couple
times to realize Richard was the
protagonist and um so we just see a
crazy dysfunctional family and the
question is well okay we're on for the
ride because boy those characters are
really interesting the filmmaker and the
writers and the actors they make that
happen so fast we're we're we're on
board I'm on board with every character
especially Grandpa snorting heroin is
just his first scene is Snort alen Arin
snorting heroin um you can just that
could be the whole the film could have
tanked and I would have paid $15 just to
see
that yeah alen Arin doesn't do bad
characters he's awesome um Ed Husker 473
I know some of my stories plot points
but I couldn't connect them how to deal
with
this
yeah um keep playing I mean that's
that's the that's the puzzle part that's
the fun that's that's kind of the um you
know we're Crea we're we're kind of like
magicians we're creating the slide of
hand how how we think about a magician
doing a car trick they're practicing
over and over and over again so they
have a slide of hand and then it seems
like nothing when they do it but they've
worked on it for months and months and
months so that's when we just try to
keep throwing dark at the board and go
how how do we put this together and at
some point maybe it doesn't work
together or at some point we have that
Epiphany after working and working and
working we're oh that's that's how it's
together I should have known that two
years
ago great I think we're gonna do one
last question and we'll go into the uh
writing exercise again and we uh Yuri
Silva from Brazil is back when I write I
didn't create the character it's like I
discovered him I feel what he feels and
I see what he sees how to combine this
Experience slash improv uh inovation I'm
sorry now now I'm improvisation excuse
me with
planning you're keeping me on my toes
Yuri thank you here's here's
some um yeah the um it's I I like your
process and then that's I mean it's kind
of probably my closer to process and
then we start to plan it's usually I'll
do a couple of drafts before I really
start outlining because I'm finding the
character and so that's important to me
and then I go wait a second okay now the
character needs to do this and this and
this I have to get here to here to here
and I maybe not I may not even know the
ending and I might not know the ending
for a year and then
usually if I'm working on it every day
the ending just comes to me and I'm like
and this and this happened on this um
last book where I was like I wrote the
ending in this like crazy Bieber pitch
and I'm like I have no idea how I'm
getting to this but this is the end and
it took me about another year to get to
that end and it's just and it stayed the
end it's just so strange that's kind of
that's the beauty of um being a writer
and just kind of sticking with it and
just going I don't know where this came
from but let's go whatever our brains do
in there when we keep showing up
they we keep showing up and we get a
little
help awesome and for those of you who
did have questions that we didn't get to
uh our apologies um so many great ones
and it's great to see so many people uh
come out for this so thank you we're
going to go to the last part of our um
live stream today which is the last
writing
exercise and um this is one you do with
a lot of your students as well Tony yeah
I I just did this at the at the library
Workshop I do in l felis once a month
and um so yeah so part one is to draw
selfportrait of yourself without looking
at the paper look into a mirror or or
your phone on selfie mode make sure to
draw as fast as possible in as real
likeness as possible without looking at
the pen or paper dare to make mistakes
dare to be awful we're writers we're not
artists and then when you're done with
that title it I'll go with this I'll do
this one as well
um so I'll look at the Monitor and try
to do a likeness of me without looking
at the page and then you can see just
how terrible you're drawing how terrible
my drawing is and how much better you'll
feel about
yours
okay great and we are back and Tony
would you do us the honor of showing
your self-portrait this is amazing I
haven't even looked at it yet so let me
see if I can oh does there we go oh wow
oh very cool actually that's better than
I thought it would
be and what's the title oh what's the
title the title is goon in a
room okay okay
and and and here again goon in a room
okay goon in a room is the
title all
right excellent so after you draw that
photo what we're going to do is we're
going to explore point of view uh so you
drew this photo now this photo is going
this this art piece this fabulous
creative thing you've just done um the
New York Met has actually realized what
a genius you are so they're hanging this
sketch next to all the great paintings
of the world and the first character
you're going to work on is an art critic
and from their point of view the first
art critic hates
this um and has a lot to say about it
think of someone in your real life if
you want to that you don't like and kind
of just picture them as the art critic
disgusted that you're this artwork is
this is the New York Met thinks this is
a masterpiece right from the point of
view of this person give them a name and
just dive into
how bad this artwork
is that'll be 30 minutes I know I don't
know how much
time this part this this part I'm not
about about five minutes three three to
five
minutes
okay and we're back so we have this art
critic and is this art critic writing
like their own uh piece on on how
horrible yes yes so you've written this
part of the art critic that is
disgusted that this that what you just
drew is at the net it's considered a
masterpiece hangs in the gallery now for
the now there's another point of view of
this and this will be the art critic
that loves this and sees the absolute
genius in this work so um yeah really
dive into this other art critic and give
them a name think maybe it's a it could
be based on a friend or someone in real
life just give him a name and let that
and just dive into this critic gushing
over this artist what Brilliance it is
to hang it at the mat of course it's
there this is everything that the
culture
needs
about what three to three to five
minutes sure yeah
yeah
all right we're back back a little bit
early I know we said seven minutes um
but it might be late for some of you
so uh so this this is the the nice
critic who who sees your
Genius and uh wants to tell the world
about you and it's and it's a beautiful
lesson in just two different points of
view which um fun to do when I when I
when I assigned this to uh classes
usually um people have a lot more ease
with the critic that's terrible about it
and they they feel really uncomfortable
writing that the drawing is good which
says so lot says so much about um our
ourselves because it's hard to
compliment ourselves and it's so much
easier to criticize ourselves yeah and
it's hard to take compliments yeah
that's really interesting well last but
not least where can we listen to drinks
with Tony oh that's on any uh podcast
where you get it uh or drinksi tony.com
and um yeah and what nights do you do
your show or is different uh it's I I
tape and then it airs on Thursday night
in s uh in San Santa Cruz on uh uh 101.9
or no it's the 92.9 FM kpcr LP Santa
Cruz and then um yeah so I just I it's
just something I've been doing for a
very long time that I just talk to
writers and that makes sense to me so
very cool well thank you Tony for uh
agreeing to come here and and yes and
try this with us and for sharing your
story again um we also have a full
interview with you
on film purage that you can check out
and thank you to all the listeners uh
we're just so honored that you came out
and a worldwide audience and again sorry
to those that we didn't get uh your
questions um hoping to do this again
sometime well thank you for for being
here and thank you Tony thank you yeah
bye